dejaron todo atrás mientras subían del
fuego california enfrenta dos de los
peores incendios en su historia por lo
que se ha ordenado la evacuación de unas
175 mil personas a través de todo el
estado a los residentes de las zonas
controladas se les permitió regresar
durante una hora para recolectar sus
cosas es horrible cuando tienes que
pensar que llevarte comida ropa y
objetos que tienen un valor sentimental
llevan lo que pueden
creo que es una emoción muy cruda tener
miedo al fuego y a perderlo todo es
aterrador
miles de viviendas han sido devoradas
por el fuego que ha consumido cerca de
un millón de acres y la fauna no está
exenta del daño la organización human
society dispuso varios refugios para
animales salvajes que han sido
desplazados por las llamas pero también
recibe a mascotas y animales de granja
abrimos nuestros refugios para que la
gente tenga un lugar seguro donde saben
que sus animales estarán a salvo que
estarán cuidados y luego cuando puedan
regresar a sus casas o encuentren otra
vivienda segura puedan venir y
recogerlas unos 14.000 bomberos han
estado al frente de la situación pero la
tarea amenaza con dificultar se se
espera que los incendios empeoren en los
próximos días alimentados por las altas
temperaturas y una gran cantidad de
rayos que podrían provocar nuevos focos